from beloved childhood favorites to the
sex icon of a generation these actors
may be gone but won't soon be forgotten
while technically the first live-action
portrayals of the eponymous Mario
Brothers came in the form of early 80s
Atari commercials Captain Lou albanos
and Danny Wells performance as the
daring Duo is probably the most beloved
they entertain millions of children
beginning in 1989 on the Super Mario
Brothers Super Show the show featured
Albano and Wells playing the two
plumbers during live-action sequences at
their Brooklyn residence often with a
celebrity guest before switching over to
a cartoon episode of Super Mario
Brothers or The Legend of Zelda Albano
and Wells also voiced Mario and Luigi in
the Mario Brothers cartoon episodes
Captain Lou was known for a prominent
professional wrestling career that
started in 1953 and ended in 1995 and he
was inducted into the WWE Hall of Fame a
year later Albano died on October 14
2009 from a heart attack at the age of
76. Danny Wells who played Luigi was
known for his TV guest appearances on
the likes of The Jeffersons Happy Days
Punky Brewster chips The A-Team Sanford
and Son and Starsky and Hutch he also
did voice acting for Heathcliff and the
Cadillac cats Batman the Animated Series
Johnny Bravo and more he died of
undisclosed causes on November 28 2013.
if you're one of the few people who made
it all the way through the Jaws
franchise to the fourth movie 1987's
Jaws the Revenge you may recognize
Judith barsi as the young granddaughter
of police chief Martin Brody before that
movie came out Farsi already had small
parts and well-known TV series including
cheers and Cagney and Lacey today she is
best remembered for two Don Bluth
feature animations she voiced ducky an
excitable young dinosaur in 1988's The
Land Before Time and animal Whisperer
Anne-Marie and All Dogs Go To Heaven on
July 25th 1988 four months before The
Land Before Time premiered Judith age 10
and her mother Maria were shot dead by
Judith's abusive father who then killed
himself according to the Los Angeles
Times a neighbor said that Maria had
lived in fear for herself and her
daughter she was trying to leave her
husband but fear he would find and kill
them both The Land Before Time and All
Dogs Go to Heaven came out after Judith
and Maria's deaths actor Heather Hogan
voiced ducky in subsequent Land Before
Time see equals Dana Hill originally
wanted to be a track star until type 1
diabetes ended her youthful athletic
dreams her father's career as a
commercial director helped her start in
the industry and she booked a series of
ads before appearing on various
television programs including Mork and
Mindy Fallen Angel and Magnum PI she
also voiced a variety of animated
characters for cartoons like Rugrats
Goof Troop and Darkwing Duck she's best
recognized for playing Audrey Griswold
in National Lampoon's European Vacation
replacing Dana Baron from National
Lampoon's Vacation a few years prior
Hill's life and career were both cut
short after suffering a fatal stroke
triggered by her diabetes on July 15
1996 at the age of 32. a classically
trained Shakespearean actor Helen
McCrory made a name for herself on stage
and in a number of fan favorite films
and television series for those who
don't frequent the London theater
McCrory was probably best known for
playing Narcissa Malfoy in the Harry
Potter film franchise other film credits
include Skyfall Hugo the queen and more
on television McCrory played Madame Kali
in Penny Dreadful provided the voice for
Stell Maria on his dark materials and
owns every scene she appeared in as
Polly gray on peaky blinders she passed
away on April 16 2021 at the age of 52
from breast cancer while filming the
sixth season of peaky blinders and
certain storylines actually had to be
Rewritten due to her untimely death
funny man Louie Anderson had one of the
most iconic voices in the world of
Comedy he was an actor whom you could
identify after just hearing a few words
from his mouth well I guess no it's a
sound and he went
and that the producer said you mean
Louie Anderson yeah
Anderson's wit in quick thinking
delivery made him a sought after
stand-up act he regularly appeared on
late night television and celebrity game
shows to help get the crowd rolling
Anderson's television career was an
interesting one early on he created a
cartoon series called life with Louis
based on his childhood in the midwest
Anderson voiced both the childhood
version of himself and his father in the
series The Show won a number of Daytime
Emmy Awards in the mid 90s Anderson went
on to appear on many other shows in
small memorable roles before becoming a
critical darling again with the FX
series baskets Anderson created the show
along with Zach Galifianakis Louis C.K
and Jonathan kreisel he starred in the
series as Christine baskets Anderson
died on January 21st 2022 from lymphoma
at the age of 68. he had kept his
diagnosis private for over a decade and
passed away just three days after
releasing information about his illness
Robbie Coltrane was a total chameleon of
an actor his characters were capable of
displaying warmth silliness and love
while also showcasing fearsome strength
and darkness to be able to do this once
or twice is impressive but to do it
again and again requires some serious
Talent
it's no wonder Coltrane was honored as
an officer of the order of the British
Empire in 2006. Coltrane jumped between
comic and dramatic roles with ease his
best known characters came from the
world of film he portrayed Valentin
zakovsky a former KGB officer and
Frenemy of James Bond in Goldeneye and
The World is Not Enough his Fame grew
even more when he was cast as gamekeeper
rubius Hagrid and the Harry Potter film
franchise playing one of the warmest
characters in a beloved franchise to
help cement coltrane's acting Legacy on
the television side of things Coltrane
regularly appeared in TV movies and
miniseries where he got to flex his
acting muscles he's probably best known
for the crime drama cracker where he
starred as Dr Edward Fitz Fitzgerald
Coltrane died on October 14 2022 due to
ongoing Health complications he was 72
years old
in the world of classic television not
many shows stand above their peers like
Happy Days it ran for over a decade of
Television featuring 11 seasons in over
250 episodes and also helped launch the
careers of notable actors like Ron
Howard Henry Winkler and Scott Baio one
other actor who appeared in every season
of Happy Days and starred in one of its
spin-offs was Aaron Moran Moran played
Joni Cunningham the younger sister of
Richie and Chuck who eventually starts
dating Chachi as the young couple
started gaining popularity on the show a
spin-off series called Joni Loves Chachi
was created this new series was about a
young couple trying to start a musical
act and the episodes featured
performances from Bao and Moran Joni
Loves Chachi was not as well received as
happy days and was canceled during its
second season the characters popped back
up on Happy Days and actually got
married in the final episode Moran
continued to find work after happy days
but never really returned to the
spotlight
she struggled with cancer later in life
and died in 2017 at the age of 56.
even if you've never seen something
she's appeared in you've probably seen
pictures of Raquel Welch Welch was a
major sex symbol in the 1960s and Beyond
she made her first Splash with the film
one Million Years BC shooting to Fame
after appearing on the film's poster
clad only in an animal skin bikini she
only had a handful of lines in the film
but that image was more than enough to
make her a household name outside of
that Welch is probably best known for
roles in films like the 1973 version of
The Three Musketeers Kansas City bomber
bedazzled and right to die she was a
regular guest on Celebrity specials and
game shows and also had recurring roles
on a handful of short-lived series like
2008's welcome to the captain in 2017's
date my dad Raquel Welch died on
February 15 2023 at the age of 82.
whether you call him the big guy or
Uncle Phil James Avery earned household
name status through his portrayal of
Philip Banks on The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air prior to making his mark on that
long-running hit NBC sitcom the Burley
actor had plenty of small roles
throughout his TV career although he was
particularly well known for his voice
acting work
but you may call me the shredder
Avery was the voice of Shredder on
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and War
Machine on Iron Man he also did voices
for a list of projects that included The
Prince of Egypt extreme Ghostbusters
fists of the North Star and Hulk Hogan's
Rockin wrestling a fatherly presence
despite his most famous character's name
Avery saddened generation of viewers
when he died from complications
following heart surgery on December 31st
2013 at the age of 68. Wendy Joe sperber
had small parts in two very big movies
she was an uncredited dancer in Greece
one of the most famous musicals of all
time and she played Marty McFly's older
sister Linda in Back to the Future
reprising the role for Back to the
Future Part 3. even before Back to the
Future sperber was well known to some
thanks to her part in the Sitcom Bosom
Buddies the show starred Tom Hanks as
Kip and Peter scolarius Henry two
friends who have to pretend to be women
in order to get an apartment in a cheap
women's only Hotel sperber played Amy
their co-worker and initially the only
resident who knows the men's Secret in
addition to regular movie roles sperber
also appeared in episodes of various hit
TV series including Murphy Brown Will
and Grace Home Improvement and Jack
sperber was diagnosed with breast cancer
in 1997. four years later she founded we
spark Cancer Center a non-profit
intended to support other patients and
their families she died on November 29
2005 at the age of 47. when it came to
the characters on Saved by the Bell the
odd man out was often Sam Powers better
known as Screech the Saved by the Bell
bunch boasted a nice collection of
stereotyped characters and Screech was
the Dork though Screech typically
appeared as a side character often
aiding the schemes of Zack and Slater
actor Dustin Diamond was still able to
Showcase his comedic talents that helped
him carve out a solid identity for a
character that could have easily been a
throwaway member of the central cast
like his character however Diamond was
kind of the odd man out of the main cast
after the show ended diamonds struggled
to land substantial roles and often
found himself at the center of bizarre
controversies a sex tape was leaked in
2006 one that diamond later admitted he
himself released with a body double
replacing him in most of the scenes
Diamond would also release a
behind-the-scenes tell-all book called
behind the bell in which he aired out
all the dirty laundry on a safe by the
Bell co-stars he would later admit that
a Ghostwriter made up almost everything
in the book Diamond passed away from
lung cancer in 2020 anyone he was 44
years old
Earl heinemann had a relatively low
profile show business career but he
stayed consistently busy for decades
appearing in movies like The Taking of
Pelham One Two Three throughout the 70s
and 80s he had his most consistent
visibility in the part of Bob Reed a
character he played in more than 450
episodes of the long-running ABC daytime
drama Ryan's hope it was a steady gig
whose reliability and dramatic potential
would be the Envy of most working actors
it was another supporting role on a
long-running series however that
ultimately earned heinemann his greatest
notoriety
howdy neighbor
most 90s kids will remember him as
Wilson the mysterious but friendly
neighbor of Tim the toolman Taylor on
the hit sitcom Home Improvement
heinemann died on December 29 2003 at
the age of 61 due to lung cancer leaving
a generation with fond memories of that
lovable neighbor behind the fence who
always had the best advice and most
interesting hobbies well hi ho Taylor
team
I am sculpting a shrine out of yak
butter
one of the original Kings of Comedy next
to Cedric the Entertainer D.L Hughley
and Steve Harvey Bernie Mac built his
hugely successful career through a
stand-up routine heavily influenced by
Richard Pryor That in and of itself
isn't unusual but Mac used that
Cornerstone to build a presence and
style that was uniquely his own I never
watched what somebody else does it does
not matter
burning man got to do his thing that
hard work paid off in Hollywood with a
series of high profile roles many might
recognize Mac as Ice Cube's neighbor
Pastor clever in the movie Friday he'd
go on to star in Charlie's Angels Full
Throttle Ocean's 11 Transformers and
more and also headline to sitcom Loosely
based on his own experiences called The
Bernie Mac Show during the last years of
his life Max suffered from sarcoidosis
which heavily affected his lungs and he
succumbed to pneumonia complications on
August 9 2008 at the age of 50.
Harold Ramis was 69 when he passed away
from an autoimmune disease in 2014 which
in and of itself might have come as a
surprise to many of the film fans who
watched him in 80s Classics like Stripes
National Lampoon's Vacation and
Ghostbusters a talented director and
screenwriter as well as a frequent
fixture in some of the biggest comedy
hits of the decade remus's behind the
scenes talents helped bring us Groundhog
Day and Caddyshack among many others in
fact he jumped back and forth between
either side of the cameras throughout
his career co-writing both of the
Ghostbusters movies as well as Stripes
although few fans knew he was Ill ramus
struggled with the side effects of his
infection for years he had to learn how
to walk all over again after Contracting
autoimmune inflammatory vasculitis in
2010 and suffered a relapse the
following year his final on-screen
appearance came in the 2009 comedy year
one a veteran of stage and Screen who
amassed a distinguished career spanning
decades Richard Harris notched arguably
his highest profile role late in his
career courtesy of the Blockbuster Harry
Potter film franchise in two of his
final screen appearances Harris played
Potter's beloved Headmaster Albus
Dumbledore in the first two installments
of the Blockbuster film franchise the
Sorcerer's Stone and the Chamber of
Secrets although he'll always be
Dumbledore to generations of
potter-loving fans outside of Hogwarts
Harris compiled multiple careers worth
of impressive credits and honors he was
an accomplished singer actor director
writer producer and songwriter who won
Grammy and Golden Globe awards for his
work on 15 different albums and more
than 70 films including Camelot The Guns
of Navarone Gulliver's Travels Patriot
Games Unforgiven Gladiator and The Count
of Monte Cristo after being diagnosed
with Hodgkin's Disease Harris died on
October 25th 2002 at the age of 72. best
known for playing the young Carol Anne
from the movie Poltergeist Heather
O'Rourke skyrocketed to instant Fame as
the sweet young girl that terrified
audiences after being sucked into the
television set in fact she may have
played the part a little too well
although O'Rourke racked up an
impressive list of credits after her
breakthrough performance as Carol Ann
she remained tied to the franchise in
the Public's mind and she was one of a
very small number of original cast
members that remained with the movie
series until its conclusion with 1988's
Poltergeist III if you've seen the final
movie you may notice that Heather's
cheeks appear very puffy and although
audiences didn't know it at the time it
was a reaction to the medication she was
taking for Crohn's disease with which
she was misdiagnosed tragedy struck on
February 1st 1988 when Heather suffered
from Cardiac Arrest while undergoing a
surgery for a bowel obstruction at the
tender age of 12. Tui Trang was best
known for her work as the original
yellow ranger on Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers but unlike a lot of actors who
start out in genre TV she seemed in no
danger of being Typecast in fact she was
developing what seemed like a
potentially promising career after
leaving the show Trang jumped right into
Feature work Landing roles in a pair of
movies released in 1996 the dark drama
The Crow City of Angels and the Leslie
Nielsen comedy spyhard clearly Trang had
enough traps to tackle work from a
variety of genres but sadly she never
had a chance to fulfill that potential
she was killed in a car accident at the
age of 27 in 2001 after the driver lost
control of the vehicle and it plunged
over a guardrail on California's
Interstate 5. emergency medical
personnel tried getting Trang to the
hospital but she died in transit the
result of massive internal injuries
one of Hollywood's all-time ultimate
that guy actors Taylor Negron compiled a
truly compressive list of classic screen
credits without ever becoming a
household name although he tended to be
on screen for no more than a few moments
at a time negron's deadpan delivery made
him a fan favorite among film
aficionados of the 80s and a standout in
pictures like Fast Times at Ridgemont
High and better off dead later in his
career Negron made memorable appearances
on hit TV shows like Seinfeld and
friends but as much fun as he could be
on screen he was even more interesting
behind the scenes in addition to acting
Negron was an acclaimed writer whose
work included published collections of
short stories as well as a trained
painter whose work was shown in multiple
galleries he was only 57 when he died in
early 2015 after a battle with liver
cancer
after making a name for himself as a
professional wrestler Rowdy Roddy Piper
branched out onto the big screen most
notably through his starring role in the
1988 cult classic they live leading that
cult John Carpenter classic Piper waged
war against a covert Alien Invasion and
coined an unforgettable catchphrase I
have come here to chew bubble gum and
kick ass and I'm all out of bubble
Piper's bone crunching work in that film
helped set the tone for a busy Hollywood
career full of B-movie roles and small
but Unforgettable appearances on
television shows like It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia on the screen as well as
in the ring Piper gave every performance
his all frequently elevating otherwise
forgettable material and consistently
serving as the most memorable component
of whatever project he was appearing in
he died in his sleep in 2015 after
suffering a pulmonary embolism that
triggered a heart attack
critically maligned and pretty much
ignored at the box office Rocky 5 is
indisputably the least loved film of
Sylvester Stallone's long-running boxing
franchise take a careful look under its
cheesier elements however and you can
see the outline of a truly affecting
story about a former heavyweight champ
going broke losing his ability to box
and nearly losing his relationship with
his son to help tell the story Stallone
brought in his own 14 year old son Sage
to play the part of Robert Rocky Jr
Balboa in the film and young Stallone's
time on the set clearly made a positive
impression after college Sage continued
working in the industry in small low-key
projects carving out a career in his own
right apart from his Blockbuster leading
father unfortunately Sage died on July
13 2012 at the young age of 36 due to a
heart attack brought on by coronary
artery disease long before he founded an
ill-fated amusement park using the
secrets of Dino DNA Richard Attenborough
was already an accomplished and
award-winning actor Attenborough starred
alongside Steve McQueen in the Great
Escape released in the midst of a busy
period that included some of his most
widely seen work he also won two
consecutive Golden Globe Awards in 1967
and 1968 for co-starring in the Sand
Pebbles and Dr Dolittle needless to say
attenborough's career contains no
shortage of highlights and his work will
no doubt be familiar to classic film
fans younger film goers however have
their own Attenborough memories thanks
to his appearance as John Hammond whose
Ambitions led to the creation of
Jurassic Park that Blockbuster made him
famous to A Whole New Generation but
it's just one short chapter in a life of
many great cinematic achievements that
ended on August 24 2014 at the age of
90.
kids of the 70s and 80s and honestly
anyone who enjoys the classic sitcoms of
the era will immediately recognize the
immortal catchphrase Gary Coleman coined
as an adorable kid on the long-running
hit sitcom Different Strokes Coleman's
diminutive stature helped him continue
to play younger characters throughout
much of his career and at the peak of
his Fame he landed a series of film and
television roles unfortunately his
youthful looks and Peak height of 4 feet
8 inches were side effects of an
autoimmune kidney disease combined with
the medications he took throughout his
life to fight the condition
work in Hollywood became harder to come
by after Strokes left the airwaves and
behind the scenes he underwent frequent
dialysis treatments and was forced to
undergo two kidney transplants after a
fall at his home Coleman died on May 28
2010 of an epidural hematoma at the age
of 42.
exactly where you remember esteemed
actor Edward Hermann from depends on
whether you favor musicals vampire
movies medical TV shows or fast-talking
mother-daughter family dramas
Herman is probably best recognized today
for his role as pompous but warm-hearted
patriarch Richard Gilmore in the series
Gilmore Girls Richard's dry sense of
humor and quiet Authority contrasted
with the quick wit and constant banter
that flew between his daughter Lorelei
and his granddaughter Rory and his wife
Emily who was played by Kelly Bishop
off-screen Hermann and Bishop both
classically trained and meticulous about
their craft were especially close
Herman's wife star whom he married in
1994 would joke that Bishop was his
other wife in Herman's final moments his
family invited Bishop to say goodbye
with them before his longest running
role in Gilmore Girls Herman worked
regularly on TV and in movies he was
nominated for an Emmy for playing a
priest in the medical drama Saint
elsewhere and won one for the legal
series The Practice
he played Franklin D Roosevelt in the
1982 adaptation of Annie having
previously played the president for a
mini-series and TV movie in the late 70s
and in 1987 he played a stepfather from
literal hell in the Vampire movie The
Lost Boys
Herman died of brain cancer at age 71 on
December 31st 2014. in the Netflix
Revival of Gilmore Girls it was revealed
that Richard had also died sparking big
changes for Emily in particular
Deezer D was one of the foundational
actors on Hit medical trauma ER born
Darren Thompson he played Nurse Malik
McGrath on the show's entire 15-year run
appearing in 188 episodes as often
happens in real hospitals as well as
fictional ones ER typically focused on
its Physicians and surgeons not the
nurses but Thompson was one of just a
handful of actors who appeared in every
season and his episode count makes him
the fifth most prolific member of the
large cast
outside of er Thompson had a few small
parts and movies including the cult
classic comedy Romy and Michelle's High
School reunion and appeared in Vanilla
Ice's video for cool as ice he played
one of the members of a fictional rap
group in the mockumentary movie CB4 in
1993 and also wrapped for real he
released multiple records including the
full-length album delayed but not denied
in 2008 and continued making songs until
his death his final track history can't
be stopped was released posthumously
Thompson started having heart issues
around 2008 telling Radar Online the
following year that he had been
suffering from recurrent pneumonia and
heart failure it was discovered that he
had a leaking valve and expanded aorta
which was addressed with surgery in 2009
according to deadline he went on to have
more operations on his heart over the
next 10 years or so Thompson died on
January 7 2021 at the age of 55 of a
suspected heart attack
Catherine Justin was in her 50s when she
started working consistently in
notoriously youth-centric Hollywood in
the mid-1990s she'd start acting in 1980
after realizing she was missing out on
following her dreams despite her late
start Justin built a career playing
one-off but always memorable characters
in hit TV series her credits include ER
Third Rock From the Sun Seinfeld
Roseanne The Nanny Frazier Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and the X-Files to name
just a few later she would add the likes
of Will and Grace and Gray's Anatomy to
that list in short name a hit show of
the 90s and 2000s and Justin probably
appeared in it her most memorable guest
appearance was as a woman who refused
treatment for kidney failure in season 1
of Scrubs the episode my old lady
consistently ranks as a fan favorite
thanks in no small part to Justin's
performance unfortunately we don't
really have a choice actually I do have
a choice
certain things you never expect to come
out of a person's mouth
I think I'm ready to die
in addition to those guest roles Justin
landed regular Parts in two major series
she played the Steely secretary to
Martin Sheen's president Bartlett in two
seasons of The West Wing combining her
talents for fast-paced drama and comedy
and nosy but occasionally helpful
neighbor Karen McCluskey and Desperate
Housewives Houston was first treated for
lung cancer in 2001. the year mild lady
aired she was undergoing treatment while
making the final season of Desperate
Housewives which was written into her
character's Ark McCluskey died in the
season finale Justin died two weeks
after that episode aired on June 2nd
2012 at the age of 72. Hugh Dane's
resume reads like a list of the top
sitcoms of the 90s and early 2000s he
played two different characters in The
Fresh Prince of Bel-Air appeared in an
episode of Martin and multiple episodes
of rock he had small parts and Friends
Sister Sister Everybody Hates Chris and
new girl on the drama side he played a
judge in an episode of The West Wing he
also appeared briefly in the comedy
movies Little Fockers and bridesmaids
however Dane will most likely be
remembered and missed for his role as
Hank the permanently unimpressed
security guard in the office he appeared
in 22 Episodes of NBC's hit mockumentary
about the inner workings and ridiculous
Shenanigans in a Scranton Pennsylvania
Paper Company Dane died at the age of 75
on May 16 2000 18. after his death his
the office co-star rain Wilson described
him as one of the greats so kind funny
and talented on January 1st 2021 NBC's
streaming platform peacock tweeted a
video of a cold open that never aired
dedicated to Dane it showed one of Jim's
most elaborate pranks on Nemesis Dwight
featuring Dane as Morpheus from The
Matrix if the blue pill is not safe to
swallow someone to tell us now
Kenny Baker originated one of the most
beloved characters in one of the most
popular movie franchises of all time but
you wouldn't recognize him from that
role out of costume Baker is most famous
for playing R2D2 the Brave and
mischievous Star Wars droid he was born
with dwarfism but it wasn't just Baker's
height that made him perfect for the
role according to his New York Times
obituary he was the only person small
enough to fit into the costume who was
also strong enough to move it it helped
that Baker had been in entertainment for
years he sang danced played instruments
clowned and ice skated in various
touring companies
as he told the guardian there are
certain close-up movements only I can do
convincingly it's all about giving R2 a
personality and CGI can never really do
that
in addition to R2 Baker played an Ewok
in Return of the Jedi alongside his wife
and fellow actor Eileen but the furry
violent inhabitants of the Jungle Planet
Endor were less fun to play than to
watch thanks to the stuffy costumes it
wasn't just that they were hot the heads
were impossible to see out of when they
steamed up
the last time Baker played R2 was for
Revenge of the Sith although he served
as a consultant on the force awakens he
also appeared in many other movies and
series including Flash Gordon Time
Bandits and Amadeus he died at the age
of 81 on August 13 2016.
if you're a millennial who grew up
wishing you could have an identical twin
to swap lives with you probably remember
Natasha Richardson best for her role as
the extremely cool fashion designer mom
in the Lindsay lohan-led remake of The
Parent Trap that was Richardson's most
prominent screen role but she had a
prestigious stage career it started with
a touring version of The Seagull which
ended in London's west end with
Richardson appearing opposite her mother
renowned British actor Vanessa Redgrave
TV fans may know Vanessa best for her
role as Dr Erica Naughton in Nip Tuck
opposite her older daughter and
Natasha's sister Jolie Richardson Jolie
should also be known to fans from The
Parent Trap era as Anita in the 1996
live action adaptation of 101 Dalmatians
as you've probably noted Natasha was
part of an acting Dynasty her
grandfather Sir Michael Redgrave
Vanessa's father was famous for
tragedies Natasha's Aunt Lynn Redgrave
Vanessa's sister was an oscar-nominated
theater Superstar to round out the
family Lynn and Vanessa's brother Corey
Redgrave was a stage actor and
playwright Natasha met actor Liam Neeson
when they starred opposite each other in
a Broadway production of Anna Christie
she was nominated for a Tony for the
role and the two later married and had
two sons together Natasha died suddenly
of head injury sustained during a skiing
trip on March 18 2009 she was 45.
in a show that made Superstars out of
its six main cast members James Michael
Tyler managed to hold his own as one of
the most memorable Side characters he
played coffee shop manager Gunther in
friends for all 10 seasons appearing in
150 episodes total although he didn't
have a line for his first 33 appearances
Tyler originally landed the role because
he knew how to work the fancy espresso
machine on the Central Perk set not one
to take himself overly seriously after
friends he played himself in the satire
episodes which saw that version of Tyler
experiencing a slightly awkward reunion
with Matt LeBlanc who played Joey on
Friends also playing himself Tyler loved
the experience of being in friends
although there was one drawback as he
told Digital Spy he was cast with very
distinctive bleached blonde hair which
added to his character's Mystique but it
was originally the result of an
experiment he let one of his friends
perform which turned into weekly bleach
jobs for 10 years Tyler was diagnosed
with prostate cancer in 2018 which he
didn't make public until June of 2021
that month he announced in an interview
with NBC that the cancer had reached
stage four meaning it had spread to
other parts of his body he died just a
few months later on October 24 2021
a veteran stage film and television
actor Richard Griffiths is known by the
masses for his portrayal of Harry
Potter's Uncle Vernon dursley while
dursley was for the most part always
cruel to the young wizard he was still a
part of Harry's family and he ultimately
helped prove that the boy who lived had
a golden heart because he still cared
for the uncle who treated him poorly
outside of the Harry Potter series
Griffiths won a slew of awards over the
course of a busy career earning
particular Acclaim for his portrayal of
English teacher Douglas Hector in a play
called The History Boys he also starred
in a variety of projects including
Superman 2 Gandhi Sleepy Hollow King
Ralph Hugo Pirates of the Caribbean on
Stranger Tides and The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy Griffiths passed
away at 65 on March 28 2013 due to
complications shortly after having heart
surgery
Brad Renfro skyrocketed to fame at age
11 through his acclaimed work in Joel
Schumacher's adaptation of author John
grisham's book The Client high profile
roles quickly followed and Renfro made
appearances in Sleepers opposite Brad
Pitt the informers starring Kim Basinger
and Ghost World alongside Scarlett
Johansson yet as his star continued to
rise on screen Renfro faced a darker
path behind the scenes one that would
ultimately see him fulfilling the sad
Destiny of many child actors plunging
into a life of illegal drug use and
trouble with the law after attempting to
buy drugs from an undercover LA police
officer Renfro pleaded no contest to
attempted possession of heroin and spent
10 days in jail on January 15 2008 at 25
years old renfro's turbulent story
reached a tragic end when he was found
dead of an accidental heroin and
morphine overdose in his apartment in
Los Angeles
Dana Plato played Kimberly Drummond in
the long-running hit television series
Different Strokes cast alongside fellow
child stars Gary Coleman and Todd
Bridges she was catapulted to instant
stardom to cope with the mounting
pressures of Fame Plato often indulge in
cocaine and marijuana off the set yet it
wasn't until she became pregnant that
the network released her from her
contract helping her trigger a downward
spiral of drugs and alcohol that
included work in adult films and a
spread in Playboy Magazine she later
moved to Las Vegas where desperate for
cash she robbed a store for less than
200 and was bonded out of jail by Vegas
Entertainer Wayne Newton
she died at the age of 34 on May 8 1999
in her RV in Oklahoma after taking a
fatal dose of lortab and Valium
best known for her work starring as Mel
Gibson's daughter in the Blockbuster the
Patriot Sky Nicole bartuziak was a child
actress with a promising future she made
her film debut in The Cider House Rules
in 1999 and starred with Michael Douglas
and Brittany Murphy in don't say a word
in 2001. she also appeared in the film
Kill Your Darlings with True Blood star
Alexander Skarsgard in 2006.
unfortunately bartuziak's life behind
the scenes wasn't as glamorous as fans
might have assumed and included some
dangerous drug habits that would end up
contributing to her having an accidental
overdose in 2014. according to
bartuziak's Mother the young Star had
also been suffering from epileptic
seizures prior to her passing which led
to the family initially believing she
choked to death before the coroner's
ruling made The Tragic Truth clear
before getting his big break Michael K
Williams was consistently cast as
one-dimensional criminals he was a young
black man in a white industry that
didn't know how to tell diverse stories
about people who looked like him also he
had a distinctive facial scar from the
time someone attacked him with a razor
something else Hollywood didn't know
what to do with
Williams Big Break came courtesy of the
wire character Omar little an armed
robber who targets drug dealers and the
most feared man in a territory ruled by
violence but little wasn't a carbon copy
of those previous characters for one
thing he was openly gay in a homophobic
society that mocked gay men as weak for
another he was known to give some of his
ill-gotten gains to people in his much
in need community
after playing Omar Williams landed roles
in several prestigious series including
crime drama the night of when we rise
about the gay civil rights movement and
a recurring part as a racketeer in
prohibition drama Boardwalk Empire he
even got to show off his comedy skills
and community in 2019 he appeared in Ava
duvernays when they see us as the father
of one of the wrongfully accused Central
Park V in 2020 he was nominated for his
fifth Emmy for the HBO series Lovecraft
country Williams died at the age of 54
on September 6 2021 of what was later
confirmed as a drug overdose
the famous jet Jackson Lee Thompson
Young Star vehicle was a very popular
show on the Disney Channel for some time
Friday Night Lights Aquila and the bee
and The Hills Have Eyes too or some of
the few films on Young's impressive
resume but while working as a series
regular on Rizzoli and Isles he was
diagnosed with bipolar disorder sadly on
August 19 2013 his life came to a tragic
end after he committed suicide with a
self-inflicted gunshot wound
Dominique Dunn was born into a life of
privilege in Santa Monica to a ranching
heiress and TV writer and producer
Dominic Dunn Dominique made appearances
in the TV shows chips Fame and the quest
but the same year Poltergeist was
released her deranged ex-boyfriend John
Thomas Sweeney murdered her in her own
driveway in West Hollywood on November
4th 1982. with a resume as long as your
arm Jonathan Brandeis showed up and
who's the boss Blossom La law Full House
The Wonder Years and Murder She Wrote
among tons of others as a child and
teenage star for many years it seemed
like he had no shortage of work he was
16 when he made ladybugs and 17 when he
was cast as a teen genius in Steven
Spielberg's Seaquest 2032 when Seaquest
was canceled in 1996 however the once
plentiful casting offers dried up
depression soon plagued the young star
he died after sustaining injuries from
an attempted suicide by a hanging at the
age of 27 in Danbury Connecticut
Lisa Robin Kelly made audiences laugh as
part of the ensemble cast of That 70s
Show but her real life wasn't funny at
all after a lengthy battle with drug and
alcohol addiction that ultimately caused
her to lose her job on the show Kelly
checked into rehab in August 2013 only
to pass away in her sleep due to
complications from an accidental
overdose she was only 43. Michael Clark
Duncan's towering physique made him a
natural for big guy roles but he really
had dramatic chops and unlike a lot of
actors booked for that type of part he
got a chance to show them his two brief
filmography includes memorable
supporting turns and Armageddon and
Daredevil as well as a beautifully
sensitive starring performance in the
big screen adaptation of Stephen King's
The Green Mile Duncan should have had a
much longer career but he was felt by a
heart attack in 2012 at the age of 54.
foreign